[Music]
okay hello everyone good evening uh glad
to see you all here i am grand master
asham already badly and this is exciting
sicilian with you
welcome welcome we have
people just could you please close the
door please thank you appreciate it
hello everyone in the chat and on on
on youtube and twitch
glad to be here with you guys this is my
last stream and the live stream with
ben simon not that i'm going to miss it
because i'm going to see him soon when i
will be back for the us championship
i've been playing i'll be playing the
u.s championship so
i'm not going to miss ben because i'll
be back in a month time so but after
that i'll miss him because i won't see
him for a few months so
that's okay i can live with that i guess
all right so today i chose six games
from the olympiad and the reason was
that usually when i talk about things uh
when i talk about different concepts
opening middle game and games i
learned just in a classical way i mean i
became a g i became an uh gm in a way
that when i became an iem
i didn't even have a laptop for my for
my chest analysis like
after i became an iem i wanted money to
to buy a lap everything was hand written
all my analysis everything i became an
in 2004. and still using databases were
not as common you know i i was born in
iran so having a laptop was was it was a
massive luxury at the time
so um
classics were very
close and dear to my heart and then i
after a while you start getting so good
at this and you just remember everything
and then you realize that it becomes so
repetitive you want new positions
so i choose a very complex content for
today not because i just want to dazzle
you with the kind of analysis or or
confuse you it's just
these things have been shown around all
along repetitively again and again so
let's do something new so olympia just
concluded few weeks ago
uzbek team with with kids averaging age
of 20 19 less than 20 won the olympiad
let's let's have a look at these some
interesting games from the tournament
so the the most difficult result for the
u.s team which finished fifth while
being the favorite was this loss against
in india b which they were averaging
maybe 17 years of age or 18 years of age
and this game between karwana and
gurkish was actually very critical
because carolina losing with whites
really didn't help the match
we'll have two wins of his later on but
the game was very interesting against
kukeshu was on a
hot streak
going 8-0
so
but again it wasn't it's not because of
the match situation but because this
game is very interesting so e4 c5 knight
three knight c6 bishop b5 i think at the
very highest level
at the very highest level of chess which
is this game
uh these guys
kind of at the agreement that playing d4
and entering swishnikov
uh
is kind of an accepted draw
okay
we have people on the chat they're
saying hi to everyone
oh
all right seems that everyone's happy
with it okay so
uh knight db5d6 so people do try to
avoid swishing on the highest level
these days so
i think that's why
uh that's why uh carolina went for
bishop b5 and he's been he's been doing
pretty good with this
um the only person who got their way
playing uh
against caruana was magnus carlson who
did well in the match in 2018 and uh
overall he has a good score against uh
caruana so the only person i've seen so
far to i'll prepare caruana in this
opening has been magnus carlsen
so
g6 is the most common response the movie
6
is playable i'm just adding that
throwing that for you but it's
you have to sit at the computer and make
the moves based on that not
not it's not really something you easily
can't play over the board although the
move e6 was gelfand's main choice
against honor in their match in 2012.
so
it's not something that new to the
highest level of chess we played in the
world championship matches but uh it's
less common so g6 is considered the more
solid one and i would assume that
cookies really wanted to draw in this
game playing black on board one
i would say he wanted a draw but he
wanted to play solid by playing the
the most solid way
so castle was played by caruana bishop
g7 and he took on c6 but this here comes
a surprise kukish went for btx c6
so
dtx c6 is considered the uh
the more uh sort of a
solid way of playing uh
so playing bc6 i'm sure uh goku has very
deep repression here but also you know
playing chess you have to play
you have to be true to yourself oh
because my opponent is stronger or is
very well prepared so then i'm not gonna
play my own line so uh i think it's very
it's very interesting that uh
it's very interesting that uh when
you're young and i think that's the
beauty of it
uh you try to be true to your principle
more often you know you become less
practical
and uh i mean in this case he's
practical because he does what he's good
at which is complex positions
um
but it's good that's why i always tell
my students and all players that you
know play true to your
your whale understanding of chess not
because oh i won't play solid because
this guy is high rated if you have this
thought then you only are thinking about
results not about your own chess and
then you cannot be true you cannot get
go beyond the point you are because you
put the rating and play and your
opponent
above your own chest and that's not the
right way to do it
i consider chess being an art so
if i compare to successful artists
successful artists didn't create their
arts for for selling them they created
them because they wanted to create them
like that
so
they call me a preach okay i'm not a
preacher no
i'm just like this so
rookie one and queen c7 and when i was
doing an analysis before the class on
chess base i saw that people on the
cloud have analyzes to the highest depth
and the move point c7 is the is the main
choice but and knight h6 is the is the
most common way of playing and the
black's plans play f6 knight f7
d6 castle and then once you go c3 d4 the
capture and the player is solid waiting
for the move e5 so i'm going to show you
some line here
just just to cover this cd and then f6
the knight goes back to f7
bishop e3 and d6 and i have i cannot i
couldn't find my own game because i
played in some some rapid or blitz game
in romania that i played h3 here uh but
anyways this has er carolina had another
game against rashid on chess.com
uh
which okay
you can already see that's his main line
but anyways he played the system and uh
yeah it's a very solid position for
white as well but i'm sure when uh
kukish was prepping this
he was sure that there is something here
because i i uh
when i was analyzing in my own word
because i played as white as well
in my analysis i think h3 is a stronger
move and after this i really
prefer
white's position or even queen d2 i
really i find it very hard to play the
move e5 because in a lot of lines i'm
just putting it it's not exactly
happening here
but after like there's a b5 like these
moves
there's always this problem of knight g5
weakening this pawn because you trade
this knight and then who's going to
defend the spawn
so
because of that
i find it quite difficult for black to
play this position
so
it requires a lot of patience a lot of
uh
you know
here's the feeling
uh psychologically it feels like you
have you have a target on your back the
entire game because your structure is
weak and you're sitting there you have
to wait for your moment
i would say not exactly a 16 year old
kid sitting there against fabiano
although they have good nerves these
young kids still it's not a comfortable
situation so i think this choice of
queen c7 is quite smart going queen c7
and playing for complex complications
yes go ahead
in that position uh before you
the played does not play e5 yeah this
position here if black doesn't play e5
like
um i've had this position with white a
couple of times i'm never exactly sure
like how to play this against someone
who's playing a little bit passively
because like a
just
make it wide open so the question was
that what if black i'm just going to
repeat for people online the question
was why black
if if black wouldn't go for the move e5
what would be your plan you have to you
have to grab space
so
in chess grid is good when you grab
space not in material but grid is good
in a space
so
yeah that's the you just keep grabbing
space because black's biggest efficiency
problem is that bishop on g7 and the
fact that he doesn't have enough space
because he hasn't pushed so many pawns
and pushing the pawns as you mentioned
could lead to some weak weaknesses that
being said black always has counters
it's not that this position is like
completely better for white
in my opinion practically
i wouldn't feel comfortable being black
in this one having a target on my back
the entire time
so but again some people i think maybe a
guy like karpov would easily play this
position at his best would have played
but it's not the modern way of playing
chess i would say so
so um
gookish's choice is quiet it's quiet uh
in accordance to modern way of playing
so you want
you want dynamic equality in all days
they want to play solid against the
stronger opponents or people highlighted
than them so that they can minimize the
[Music]
minimize the gap by you know making
solid moves but nowadays
these guys know deeply what they are
doing and they can be faster so they can
put more pressure on you so where
actually the difference narrows is in
dynamic so the difference between the
top player and someone somewhat a little
bit less less
100 points below them is not in
in the statics
well sorry isn't the stat it's not in
the dynamic actually it's another way
around so
maybe a strong ian could get a draw
against the gm by playing solid now they
have more chance by playing more more
dynamic more dynamic because more
younger players are more inclined to be
good at calculation so it makes a lot of
sense
hello everyone in the chat welcome
so queen c7 h3 the move d6 was played
these are all according to the engine
and the mov e5 is a very interesting
move i'm gonna put a
sign here for it it's a pretty pretty
good move
uh
everyone from youtube and uh
and twitter sorry twitch twitter
yeah of course yep so if i was played
this is a very
interesting move
disintegrating the pawns and then he
plays d3
and here i'm gonna give everyone a
minute to think what was kukisha's move
which actually i'm sure he had prep but
it makes a lot of sense what does black
do here in this position
well then you can go back with your
bishop but i mean i see we're saying but
anyways it's a pawn that you're going to
lose in the center anyways
um
so he has to complete his development
that's correct but if i get to do this
and then these pawns become if i play f6
and surprisingly like for example let's
say i go f6 let's say i just try to
reinforce this
and then surprisingly this i go here
this and then i go knight c3 knight at
six to say i don't care for example and
then all of a sudden i become extremely
active white pieces because of the
massive leading development wise
position becomes really really really
good
all of a sudden
so
here
goku should play this very interesting
move c for someone in the chat said
uh
to prevent 192964 but more importantly i
cannot take on c4 because if i take on
c4 and this is where dynamic comes in
play black just play f5 before and black
is just better right
yep black is just better
so
c4 was played in the game knight c3 and
the players were were lashing out their
moves so basically they were both in
their preps still
c takes d3 c takes d3
knight h6
knight x e5 obviously capturing on e5
leads to bishop t6 yeah sorry just let
me thanks
um
knight takes f5 uh and then bishop of
four was so here um another five bishop
before they were both playing their
preparations
knight day four
and then f6 i am not so sure about this
move this is the first move i am going
to put a question mark not that i
believe it's a question mark because my
analysis
isn't deep enough to say if i am really
at the point that i can really say uh i
can um
i can overrule black's play by saying
it's just it's a bad move but it surely
doesn't really
address what i was really thinking black
should do i was thinking more of a
bishop e6 bishop d5 things like this and
it seems that black is doing all right
but there's also this knight c5 here
so maybe engine would say take on b2
wouldn't be my choice
engines
say moves like this
i cannot let this happen
maybe maybe then castle first rook c1
then bishop e6
knight c5
can't you take the c6 pawn with the
knight the other night
here no take on c6 and i just take on a2
everything is protected here okay
what was the question was the other
question
this this queen before
yeah looks very bad
looks very bad this is hanging we are
not castled yet
well i'm not so sure still i mean after
this bishop before engine was very cool
but this is like i'm not talking about
the leeches engine i'm just having
delicious engine to avoid blunders so if
i make it blunder it will show that i i
may blunder in my comments but i don't
trust this evaluation or whatever it
says but when i was looking in the cloud
it was saying this position is playable
for black but again it's according to
the engine
and the way i see it with my old school
understanding of chess what is way ahead
in development has a good grip of dark
squares and i'm really having trouble
making moves here
so
but i'm sure i was looking at the times
walking into this position goku
shouldn't just come randomly playing his
position
i mean simply cannot do that against
caruana so
um
i doubt f6 was a prep he probably was on
his own
but uh yeah engine says moves like queen
b5 bishop e6 things like this
well the thing is that he cannot play e5
some people say well f6 e5 gets the
control of the center that's the problem
he cannot play e5 here because if he
goes e5 then there's d4 and that's it
game over because of the pin and in the
game you cancelled and then d4 and
there's no e5
so that means it puts the entire concept
of black's play into question because
i have a bad bishop i weaken this square
and i have not very good pieces now
so
it's it's a
i cannot really personally endorse this
concept in here the way black played it
so
yeah this remains to for further
analysis i i'm actually important in the
process of writing an article about the
olympiad and i might run the cloud a bit
further there so if that will come out
in with justin format you guys can see
it there or it will probably so i'm sure
no i'm not the only person who's looking
at this so we'll see
people will will address this at some
point
but to me it's it is the critical moment
in this game that i don't like this
movie f6 at all
that's what he played yes
so this there d4 and then kukesh goes g5
and here on
i couldn't really follow what
what uh caruana is doing for example
this seemed to me
like a no-brainer
or bishop h2 or bishop c7 it says
controlling a square seems like black is
absolutely out of any move because i'm
about to play like queen a4 and rook b1
i mean all kinds of queen d3 i just know
where the pieces of black species are
going and if he doesn't take say goes
queen b6 then just bishop d2
because in the game he played bishop h2
which is still okay i think after this
he is still better but
i mean
am i missing something here seems like a
very simple way of playing of course
there are things here you have to kind
of make sure about there b4 knight f3
queen f3 but again
where is this bishop going
e5
rook c1
again where is this bishop going
good
yeah but then just the knight e4 now the
sky is hanging and look back f8 you have
to 96 or bishop e3 or queen b3 check
bishop oh sorry queen b3 check and then
bishop e3
yeah there's no score for the bishop so
i
yeah i
quote again i don't because i have other
games to show and uh
we have only an hour so i only can't say
that
i don't understand
i don't understand why he never played
knight c5
i don't understand why caraway he never
played knight c5 in this in this
position so he played there there now
for example again knight c5 right it's
not as powerful now with the bishop on
his two because g4 is coming but it's
still knight going to c5
now okay it's it's a lot still you have
to kind of go knight c5 he played he
played rookie four
then queen d7 queen c2 fine then here
and now it's not any more strong because
the queen comes to this by the way this
was a very strong move queen d7 this was
a very strong move regrouping with the
queen on d5
is a very strong move because if i go
that back to c3 there's always bishop e7
c5 coming so he found this he found the
he found the balance for his position
queen c2
knight there
rook to e1
and bishop f here bishop f8 was played
and uh
and carolina goes queen e2 which is
still drifting i mean i i would like to
see some a3 before
maybe
but already it's very hard to play i
mean engine still gives some advantage
for white but i just don't
i find it quite difficult to play as
white because whatever you do is very
committal
and it's not that easy to make him make
him move here for white in this position
which move
maybe
because that piece has to do something
a5
black pawn no a5 gives this a square
it's this one i'm talking about white
has a heart white has a hard time to
play
now white has a hard time making a3 like
queen d8 it's but still i mean he gives
away so
how about knight
d6
knight to d6
knight d6 is not good
which move not which after a3 like you
mean no 96 no no but you just yeah i
understand but i mean yeah it's not it's
not now it's don't worry it's knights
comes to e6 no black is
knight is good he wants to put the queen
here right yeah queen d5
okay
yeah so
knight c3 queen d7 back and then uh okay
again rook d1 d5 something again he goes
queen c4
queen
b7 and what has no threat
and then gradually suddenly he played
before e6 and suddenly black species are
all
back to functioning
it would have been better on c5
well now that
now you the bishops of the b4 parts i.e
yes
it's the game i'm going forward through
the game yes
queen d7 look back to e1
he goes back to b7 he's repeating once
and then
sorry let me continue this thank you um
uh
look back to b1 repeated a couple of
times and then he goes for a3 which is i
understand with the team situation being
difficult on board for
dominguez was losing in the sicilian as
well against sajwani
he was trying to play for the win but
again this was not the way to go because
a3 gives just a5 now and now after uh
and now after uh
the move uh
hello mj
so now after this move all these pieces
are suddenly active and the queen knight
a4 queen d8
caron is trying to be active but then
suddenly
black is extremely active this is
structure is very strong
and then queen d5 very strong move yeah
this is this is the blunder it's the
final blunder knight c5 the final
blunder
so
queen d5
and uh now
yeah he has to go back yes so he has to
go back and then well the point is that
after this is just very hard to play
so
queen e2
uh rook takes a3
yeah well very funny comments on
on on youtube
so uh um
look to d1 and then yeah this was not
just going well so anyways going back to
the to the keep moment i don't i don't
want to go through the entire game
yeah here is the point that he
yeah got lost in all these complications
with the
f6 so
i really don't know why the engine likes
the smooth queen c7
and this seems to be all according to
the engine's best moves in the on the
board right
yep and uh
knight h6 was played knight takes e5
knight f5 and then bishop of f4 queen b7
all according to the engines and he
played knight a4 all these are normal
moves
and i don't know
if this is the best black handy or
bishop leads to just that pressure
why would be the trend but apparently i
think we'll see more of this coming
because
that's where it goes okay
so not a great day for caruana in that
game but any at these two back-to-back
wins after that or maybe the one next to
i'm showing next one is before that this
is a more inclined classical toward the
english attack so
this was our bishop b5 which was an
interesting game
and still i'm
befuddled by the whole course of the
game and i have to dig deeper but
i'm glad i shared it with you now
um
let's look at this game of of course
against the
[Music]
iranian super gm maxillo
this game is a very interesting one
i really liked it
and there are so many correspondence
games in it which we're going to look at
and it has it has a very interesting
tactical battle and this is one game
that although he lost that game and the
u.s team lost but this was caruana's win
that win the match for the us team so um
the typical
opening
and we have this very famous uh
position that have been pl that has been
very topical
in the top level
um
b4 is less common these days but uh i
checked the iranian players the gm's
they played quite often so they might
have worked on it together
um
this is uh
i think is it a trend
no it's not this is not the one
oh okay
here okay sorry caruana played my bad my
bad after b4
this is the trendiest way of playing
that was played
at the uh
at the candidates hello saran
uh knight e8 and then they go here f4 a5
f5 and a4 and it's a very long
uh theoretical battle which leads to an
equal end game but they both have to
know it
um
this openly been around since 2007
uh
but here carolina opted for something
less forcing
and he played before any two kind f6
which
according to my analysis and works with
the
uh look at the correspondence games
it's
quite challenging for black and it has
some some forcing nature at some point
so after the move we take c3
queen takes c3
knight takes f6
and he went knight a5 which is the best
move otherwise i mean i have to make use
of this square another move that is very
common here is knight a4 and it's a very
common uh
opening correspondence games knight h5
quintix b4 d5
queen a5
bishop takes g5 just this one is just
remember this is under attack
queen this and then um
this is uh my chord is a two to the
participants in this class know that
bishop g5 is a bad move leads to a worse
end game slightly worse end game whereas
d4
uh or is it queen takes a5 sorry queen
takes a5 captured d4
after bishop knight c6 bishop d6 all
forcing king b1 fc8 leads to a draw
according to a bunch of correspondent
schemes when as it leads to a draw it's
a complex position where black has
enough compensation for the pawn because
these knights are not so great
and it's very hard for black for white
to regroup in fact if black could have
taken this knight back to the game he
could even play for a win
so
this is the best way in my opinion to
play and if somebody knows that it must
be played but after them will bishop g5
bishop takes back on g5 queen takes back
on g5 king b1
d takes e4 there's one move here for
white which i want to give everyone some
time to think about it
and
see if you can find it that gives white
a good edge in the end game so let me
give you a couple of minutes to think
about it what can black do
yeah and people are saying on the chat
that they don't like to be befuddled
okay that's good let's stay away from it
so here white has a move that
i don't give you the double x clamp
because double slam usually wins the
game but this point is a very strong
move that gives white a slight edge in
the end game
so
nuts michael i'm i'm talking to people
online no not not bishop c4 nope
remember there's this move coming
but there's a very small tactical idea
something tactic with the tactical idea
that
the game that looks pretty good for a
black flip city what's that
you get a4
h4 h4 i just moved the queen
that's no it's exactly the movement
knight d4 it's a very beautiful movie
using the lateral uh
pin
now
we want to take this bishop and take
this knight making making it forced for
black to go back with the queen to e7
now we take
we take this bishop getting rid of this
push up and after queen takes e6f takes
e4 now in terms of material the position
is balanced
black has black has a majority on the
queen side with four versus two
versus two and on the king side sorry
and white has a majority on the queen
side with three versus one
now i'm going to ask one question though
if we are removing the queens who is
better
it's a very important judgment call
if you remove the queens of the board
who is better
white is better and why
no no no not not like that i mean think
conceptually say there's no tactic
it's conceptually white is better why is
that
uh it's one of the reasons but it's one
of the minor reasons not the major ones
so it's but it is one of the reasons
he's got
a better majority because black playing
the move f5 is not an easy one to do
so because if i can take and the central
passes are not great and so when i teach
this to you know beginners and one of
the beginners of people who are getting
getting together get the ropes around
with the strategy i tell them in the
opening and middle game we try to move
toward the center in the end game try to
go to the edges to the because then
without the queens on the board
your activities on the side your
opponent needs to
do to gravitate to things toward your
pieces to bring the pieces toward
your majority where you are pushing your
pawns is a much more uh
much more difficult task
it's much harder to bring their pieces
toward uh your piece to decide that your
pieces are more active because it takes
more tempo whereas when the queens are
there if they have a couple of pieces
they can come up with good combinations
against your pieces so
that being said
i'm gonna give one example where the
queens go off the board
this is a game in correspondence chess
and it's actually even more crazy he has
he has
four versus one basically he has two
passes and one and then we have three
ones and this one
um
well actually i featured this one i
think in in my book uh co-authored with
sabine sherlock's method is kind of
winning for for white and there is only
one miraculous defense which i think
black even in the correspondence game
didn't find it but the problem black has
are three the bishop the bishop the side
pastors the the far um the further to
the edge of the board passes
what's the correspondence game are the
ones played where people are not playing
in real time over the board games
whereas they just email each other the
ones they have and they have like 10
days to make 20 moves basically that's
how it goes basically they have a lot of
time running their engines and that's
what uh the correspondence games are
well they're essential for chess
development of theory because you know
all these ideas someone has to have a
lot of time to do it right
or the board is not like that huh
so um b4 f5
c4 king f8 king b2 and the problem again
because i have central pawns it's very
easy to move towards center there's a
few tempe whereas you see how much
temple tempe
it costs
this the black king on e7 costs to get
closer to the pawns
so king rook c1 king d8 c5 rk7 bishop b5
and just gradually you see now we are in
an even equal situation but now white
spawns are far far more advanced than
blacks so he goes c6 check king
okay here here's when the engines work
matters because a lot of time you would
think i have to go forward with my king
but when you run the engine
you see that king b3 doesn't win but
king b1 wins on the spot and that's the
engine work basically
so uh yeah and black ended up winning
this uh
white end up winning his end game so the
move knight a4 though
been around and and over the top level
chest but
not as often because i think they had
only figured out that d5d4 which i told
you but a lot of people
more lower the players happen to not
know that and go for that end game which
i just showed you so if you are playing
this
i would suggest you to test your
opponent if they've got knight h5 sorry
if they go like this you go knight a4
and c after knight h5 queen before they
know the plan d5 d4 obviously you have
to spend time learning the other line as
well
so
um
car 104 gtx f6
so for strong players i suggest you to
study this
for weaker i mean i would say figure
four for app for club players i suggest
them to take play knight a4 that's my
suggestion
so for professionals
yes and people saying knight a4 is quite
diff different yes that is it is true so
okay the gtx f6p takes c3 capture
capture knight a5 as i said this knight
is heading here to take this bishop
which black is fine with because it's
kind of forced now the knight is pinned
i need to save
and to save myself from losing material
by taking on e7
captures and queen goes to a5
some people are asking online if i move
if i suggested more common knight e2
which was i told you the most developed
line
um
i would recommend that only if you you
are willing to spend time memorizing 45
moves all the way to the end game
it's not my thing i would i don't i
wouldn't do that but against a very
strong opponent i may end up doing it
depends where i'm okay with the draw if
my opponent knows everything
again it comes down to the situation
white goes to queen a5 and rook c6
and rook g1 is the strongest move
according to the engine
just you know getting ready to improve
his pieces
rook fc8 king b1 taking on taking on c2
is not an option due to bishop takes a6
and looks c1
because if i get the looks off the board
then i'm winning with the two a a and b
and two bishops
knight h5
it goes to g2 so this is this was the
idea so i first i've saved one tempo and
now the g2 does the job also it's
eyeballing the idea of going to putting
pressure on this is combining an
attacking defense at the same time
uh some people are saying that it used
to be the thing it used to be a thing
especially in 2007 at waikanse anand won
a beautiful game from black side of of
that against karjakin and it used to be
very trendy
back in early 2000s
late 2000s and early 2010s
however
the move top level is fading because
when everybody is studying it they know
how to make it draw in that line with
92.
so i was just answering the question
people had it online because i have to
i'm looking at the chat as well too
so queen f6 attacking the spawn rook f2
i kind of that's the move that makes
sense right
so this rook is doing a great job with
being on f2 it defends so many things at
the same time
so okay this is a very good question
what do you think of the move bishop g5
in the opening the the
the uh i'm just going very quickly back
to address that very quickly
um people are asking in this position
the line with bishop g5
i suggested to all of my students
because most people do not play the uh
so if if some people like to play
english attack i suggest i suggest them
to play the knight a4 system if they
want to
if they want me to choose for them what
to play here i such as bishop g5 because
for the most players below this level
2600 level nobody takes their time to
memorize
queen b6 which is the poison pound which
is leads to a good position for for
black so most of the classical systems
which lead to a comfortable position for
white so if you are playing there is a
good chance your opponent wouldn't know
wouldn't play the move queen b6 so
i suggest my students to play the move
bishop g5 if
but if they choose to play the uh
english attack like this game
then i am
i am an adamant uh
uh
uh
uh some
big uh
i recommend that move uh
i'm an element supporter and the
recommender of the move uh
knight a4 here
this is move94 okay let's continue with
this because i answered too many
questions online
uh takes quintex c3 knight takes f6
knight a5 again going there we had this
position already we know what's going on
here okay needless to say this capture
is impossible due to rk8
rook g1 it's a very important
multi-tasking move because now the rook
ends up being here the king will land on
b1 because you just want to make sure
that there's no tactic there and
remember if white consolidates having
two bishops and the spitfire structure
on the queen side would lead to just
simply better position for white
because he has all the means that so
black should have used the means of
tactic to kind of stay current in the
game and i think this is where
this is where he made the mistake
actually knight h5 because he gives this
this maneuver engine likes to smooth d5
and that's the most common line
uh
played
i don't know this line very well and
this guy's in 2700 and he's played this
one twice before i'm sure he had done
his homework before and just to mention
the movie takes d5 is not possible
because after capture capture i cannot
take twice on d5 because i have a
background issue we can attack another d
file and i'll have problem
so
um
they go moves like p3 d4
and the pass results shows that
in correspondence and over the board
black has been doing all right so they
moved knight h5
two reasons either he was trying to play
for a win because
we already know carolina did not have a
good tournament so he was maybe trying
to take some risks to win the game
or he simply
wasn't confident his analysis in d5
queen f6 or kf2 so far theory and he
played queen h4 and this is a this is a
novelty but
and it seems that caruana didn't know
much about this move because the
engine is not so thrilled about seeing
this move and just says you can just go
before and play it which is
which is really odd but it's not as odd
when you see game four where although
white lost the game the pushing response
is is part of the game
which is crazy that
when i teach when i teach sicilians say
you don't go along castle don't touch
those pawns as much as you can and then
you analyze with the engine and you say
oh
cool be four plus two
and then i have to explain you know what
you kind of have to know all kinds of
techniques to to be able to
consume that kind of knowledge
um
caruana is only four players so but okay
carolina is maybe
one of the biggest experts in the
opening in the world so this
good enough h6
and corona positionally you know
realizes the advantage so
they repeat once it goes by queen e1
which is not the greatest move either
but he's being very practical you know
he understands that endgame is good for
him and his opponent failed to create
counter play now this knight therefore
thing he didn't create anything so he
made some moves here but somehow
it didn't go through for him so queen he
won so not necessarily engine moves but
white is on the right track he wants to
trade the queens get that ending we just
saw not exactly in game but two bishops
and
the majority he's looking for
their
c4
i'm not so sure if i like this move
either
but okay you played that f5
bishop f4
again he's trying to get the end game
king
b2 the sad thing about black's position
what is the lack of the counter play and
the problem is that he has a very bad
pawn structure
queen f6
carolina back there rook f7 bishop c2
and now this is a fixed target black has
no real because
pushing the pawns will just this time
weakens black's king i cannot really
just go f4 g5 g4
queen d8
okay gives away the tactical shot okay
now it's all game over
and i cannot play queen f6 because of
queen b7 so he goes gf6
and this loses a pawn
and
the rest is just
too easy for carolina even if he's not
in his best chef
his best shape so yeah
so it was a very interesting tactical
battle and there is so many interesting
games i added here i'm not going to go
over it but
so many games with king b1 and then uh
rfc8 here
king b1 and then yeah this d5 was
expected but somehow
white black didn't go for it so as we
can see
this level all these analysis all they
work on these things and uh comes down
to one half a tempo basically
very very
yes isn't he
well i'll ask him next time i talk to
him my honestly i'll ask him
yeah
don't talk to him often
time time difference and also the fact
that
these guys are professionals i do my
thing as a coach and everything but i
talk to him from time to time right now
he's he's playing the turkish league so
if i talk to him i'll ask him sure and
if i if i'm around here next week
then simon's not gonna be here but i'm
gonna be here so
i'll i'll i'll make sure to address it
but sure okay so i'm gonna go to the
next game
another
another um
bishop v7 ah there also i can explain
this to you uh on the iranian team
there's the grandmaster danny he just
entered top 100 in the world and he's a
huge expert of uh of neither he's
playing like since he was like 16. and
he's like 26 now 10 years and he was
like always up to date in night of uh
refer to rm prep so and they all prep
together so it could be that you know
sharing files and everything but it also
could be that you know if you don't have
the feeling for the position you still
cannot live up to the
expectation
of of your play so
like for example when i
get the end game in in berlin i feel
very confident against any player
whereas
not maybe feeling the same in other
openings so it all again comes down to
what kind of position you get so he
probably
had the right prep to a certain point he
either either forget forgot or he uh
simply
doesn't feel that comfortable playing it
okay so let's go back here
so this time you must play this system
and he played knight as far so he's the
one who actually deviates your noise
goes h5 so knight h5
and uh
now
carolina goes king b1 which is one of
the common modes knight d5 is the most
common but carolina probably had
analysis all over the place with
everything so he just tried to play the
lesser common ones because his opponent
probably did not check this which kind
of paid off because knight b6 is the
most common move and again knight d5 is
the move and here carter want to play
queen to f2
it's not the greatest move on the board
everything is playable
but the most important thing is that
he's throwing off his opponent
knight c4 bishop takes c4 b takes c4 and
where does this knight land
a5 yes the knight goes to a5
uh knight c5 also is a move
but i personally don't don't take any
interest i mean it's it's not that much
pleasure to play this position to me i'm
kind of help i feel like helping black
but the engine is cool oh sorry
the engine is cool with it
that's the only reason i don't like
online chess mouse slip
you know in a real game i never must
live
so and actually in in 2020 at the end of
2020 because of kobe the qualifier for
those championship was online and if i
had won my last round game
i could be in an armageddon with with
alex slenderman to to play
and the winner of the armageddon would
would play
the u.s championship 2021.
what happened was i was going to play
queen to d7 i hun i dropped it on d8
the game didn't draw so
well but this is what it is i mean it
was the same it was a classical game so
i got excited well
to be fair i didn't see it was winning
but my intention was 27 which was a
winning move
so
i wasn't as on sad until i realized
after the game that it actually made a
huge difference but my intention was d7
so um
so knight a5 was playing this game
knight c5 is also a game was played in
correspondence games now the fight was
played by
uh caruana
rook c8
uh
knight d5 was played rook bishop d5 rook
d5 all seemed pretty natural and normal
white only has one problem here right
that's the knight on a5 because yeah
well if you get to play knight b7 knight
takes d6 that would be fantastic but
it's doesn't seem as easy to to achieve
to play knight p7 there so the first
move comes in mind is to play queen c7
right you defend the pawn you don't let
the knight come to b7 and uh
your plan is to improve this time which
is probably you want to play f6 here or
maybe some f5 depending on the situation
obviously
the first look we just look at this
these two pieces the knight on a5 and
the bishop on e3 are superior to their
counterparts in black's position
but
this pawn makes a huge difference
so that's why i was very surprised i was
very surprised
okay people are asking online wasn't the
night just hanging on 85 okay i have to
explain very quickly the knight is not
hanging because after queen takes a5
bishop b6
queen before a3 and oops the queen is
trapped so just adding four people
online
so
so knight a5 looks see it covering this
is knight d5
still cannot take on a5 because of
knight x7 check bishop takes d5 rook
takes d5 and i was very surprised seeing
this move
played by
here is the
yeah okay
okay i should zip it then i cannot
continue talking about this because i'm
sure
he the author is here yes
so
so i i think queen c7 was uh the way to
go
uh
but then giving the chance of this night
coming back to the game seemed a little
bit uh
not not the right way to go by the way
for those who were
yeah yeah fabinho was here so
well i'm not gonna get to asking
firsthand later on that what was the
deals
what's that
he does i think i think yep well but
these guys have to travel a lot playing
tournaments so take i was very surprised
with letting this knight getting back to
the game
uh and look this is i i was wondering if
this move knight b7 is actually stronger
capture capture queen c7 1916 t1
looks like pretty strong as well
but anyways this also looks pretty good
and uh
this knight comes to the game via c6
seems that
black missed something really big here
to me it doesn't make any sense to let
this knight come to the game because
white had everything in the center right
so you have to make sure that you don't
just let the wise pieces get into the
motion
and uh played f5 with the knight c6 okay
now i cannot play fe4 why couldn't i
play fe4 i forgot
h4 right
now h4 goes yeah h4
now i have 9697 check
because the queen cannot cover this
score yeah that was it
h 497 checks coming
yep
so
rook ce8
queen c5 and this is just game over so
king h8 takes the pawn yeah the rest is
just a matter of i mean you cannot take
here because i have seven check
and just
yep
the
this is really hopeless
pawns running here
knight f6 takes and then uh rook f7
doesn't work because of knight d5 rook
g8
this is hanging
these are all everything's hanging so
e5 is probably not good because of
knight f4 now e5 is not good i just i
think i just pick up the pawn
and then a6 is hanging everything's
hanging this end game the a point will
be decisive
anyways
how are we doing on time i would be
happy to take questions because i will
not be able to complete the next game
that will at least need 15-20 minutes
so i'll be happy to answer your
questions
any questions for me yes i kind of got a
weird question um
so
uh do you know the bond structure from
like a c3 sicilian
where black plays d5 uh-huh so basically
white has abc and black and white also
has fgh okay he's missing the e5 and
b-box yeah i know i know what the
structure okay so
from you were talking about end games a
long time earlier in the lecture
is that structure better for white in
the ending
it all depends on the situation there is
no concrete there is no there is no
there is no uh
exact answer to that question that i
mean depends on where the pieces are
where because you know in in french
defense i'm just let me show you very
quickly in french defense it happens all
the time like people play this opening
yep
and take queen takes d5 not gf3
i mean i'm just making one of the just
playing one of the lines
i mean castle knight c6 knight b3
[Music]
knight f6
knight takes d4 knight 64. i can't play
queen x d4 i go to the end game well if
it was right everybody would have played
this whereas nobody plays this actually
everybody tries to keep the queens on
the board to play for it when that's
white so they just go you know capture
and then bishop d7 for example
this is pretty all right because white's
pieces are black speeds are quite okay
actually i have a win in this position
myself from black side obviously my
opponent didn't play well but
uh
no this you cannot just say that well
now if i remove all the pieces and for
example keep the d file for white
with the rooks then yes then you have a
majority that which is easy to push
whereas if black takes the d-pawn is not
as
you cannot say be as confident to say
that so in the rook end game if i am
controlling the d-file
then yes it's very good for white
now if a minor piece and game
i would say it's easier to play as black
so it all depends on the pieces you have
on the board that's the answer to it
yeah
do you have any questions ben online
uh
no i mean there is a question that asks
do you take questions from the chat
i was going to i mean we have one
question
uh
there's one question about which what i
consider
especially as drewish
i think nowadays
after the match between caruana and
carlos and caruana i think most people
are just really this is the only way to
go for the play for the win although
probably at that level has already been
has already been solved but i really
this used to be something but now it is
it really doesn't lead to anything
there's very little to room to play for
for for white here a6 they used to play
they used to really take this one
seriously and they were hoping that
there is something for white but
the more they play it the lesser i see
things for
for white here so
that's what that's what people try to
avoid that's i'm sure if it was going to
happen especially
caron wasn't going to enter this
position i'm sure about that
okay
um thank you everyone i hope you enjoyed
the lecture and uh
we're i'm gonna be here next this
tuesday ben's not gonna be here so as i
said we're not gonna miss ben but that's
okay we're going to be okay with that
and that's it for me ben anything else
no it's been really great
thank you thank you have one thanks my
pleasure
thank you
[Music]
you